what up guys welcome to the just hly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sit down today I have a special
guest on the channel welcome to the show
Malik Obama hey thank you guys everybody
thank you for having me yeah thank you
for coming appreciate so um where where
did you say you're from again I'm from
Kenya originally from Kenya East Africa
yeah but I've been living here since
1985 okay yeah um so what is like the
biggest culture Al difference you notice
between in Kenya and here uh well here
people are extremely aggressive and uh
about their independence and over there
people more like uh disciplined like in
terms of like uh they follow culture and
most of it is like from the custo
Customs culture and traditions from ages
ago and uh so it's it's different and
that I guess
the way they look at life you know and
their family structure yeah yeah so it's
different how because we always hear how
bad the West is in terms of the culture
would you say it's a lot worse
here not really well it all depends
because here a lot of people look at it
as like there's a lot of it's the uh the
big big buildings of um there's
abundance yeah of things you know and
over there because of the colonial he
the history yeah whereby you know the
traditional custo culture and customs
and and way of living has been altered
in that uh the concept is that what you
have is not as good as what was brought
and the colonial times people were
actually
forced to sort of like change the way
they were living towards this other way
of living so right now you find that you
know their view of
Western culture is that that's where
that's what they want because they see
that is like uh development advancement
that's where you
know the world is going as opposed to
going backwards and wearing skins and
living in like mud tached houses yeah
but people are thinking like they want
to electricity they want to have more
money they want to drive cars you know
they want to wear like you know good
clothes you know um and uh things like
that they want to have like food a lot
of food different types of food you know
and so forth and then with the education
system over there you know it's not like
you're being educated about the way you
used to be but you're being educated
about the way the world is right now you
know so it's uh it's difficult because
here you have your culture and at at the
same time you have to live the way that
it is right now where you know if you're
going to have tea you need sugar yeah
you know that kind of thing and if
you're going to be cooking you need you
know cooking oil and if uh then you have
to go to school so you have to have a
job you can't just have subsistance f
coming and then you have your maybe it
is your your your cow that your milk and
then you have your milk or it is your
farm that you farm and then you eat off
of that where that's in Kenya yeah in
Kenya okay yeah we don't have I don't
have a cow here no you don't you don't
so things are not as regulated here and
it's a bit more loose loose because you
can keep chickens at home yeah and I
here you know in in the Western World I
think they have their l La against yeah
everything's more regulated yeah so it's
it's a different but a lot of people
don't understand until they come here
and then it's very different because
they are thinking that they can adapt
you know and it's difficult to adapt
because you have to be born in this
rather than you know learn you know a
lot of stuff yeah so it's it's difficult
so are you and Barack Obama Are You full
Brothers
no did you grow up together we didn't
grow up together uh we heard about each
other growing up I did I don't know
about him um my father would say oh this
is your brother and so forth and show me
pictures we didn't get to grow up
together until 1985 when I came to the
United States okay you know and then
somewhat we got in touch and everything
and that's how you know physically we
came to know one another and who we are
yeah his mother's different and our
fathers are the same okay so it's the
same so that's how it is so how old were
you when you met him 85 I'm thinking
shoot if I can count that's uh that was
27 27 and how what's the age Gap are you
guys the same age no we are three years
apart I'm I'm the old I'm older than him
by three years yeah I was born in 58 and
he's born in
[Music]
19661 yeah and were you guys close when
you met in the beginning yes because we'
like we lost lost long lost brothers and
we found each other okay you know so we
were trying to like catch up
and yeah so we were really close we just
like with me I just took him as I
didn't bother to try to find out what
his background was you know it's almost
like you find like a
$5 bill and you put it in your pocket
and that's how it was with me and him so
I didn't try to question anything I just
accepted him for who he was and he also
accepted me for who I was and was civil
towards each other you know we were
really nice to each other we didn't say
any bad things so growing up you know
how you grow up with somebody and you st
you can fight yeah you know you can
fight over something maybe you know you
you have some toys or something like
that and you fight and everything but we
didn't have the luxury because we didn't
grow up with another that so the
pressure was to be nice so we were
always nice to each other very civil but
maybe you didn't know like the negative
Parts about him because you guys just
didn't grow up together no yeah I didn't
know and I wasn't even interested in
knowing about I just like wanted to keep
a good relationship with him and
everything and hey brother and this kind
of thing so and that's how it was you
know yeah you guys were so close you
were the best man or he was the best man
in your wedding yes he was
I was the best man at his wedding and he
was the best man at my wedding you know
so we try to keep it's like we were very
close and the ties were supposed to be
very close nothing so if it was a big
thing like that I went over there and
his mother was alive at the time so that
kept us even closer because the mother
was very nice to me she treated me as
her her child you know long lost child
and all that stuff so she kept
everything together you know so when uh
he was about to get married so he called
me and say brother look I want you to
come and you know I want you to
represent the old man the old man is
like that our dad you know so I went
over there and I was the best man and
then the same thing is when I got
married and then he was my brother so
you know who does anything without his
brother right so I I got him over and he
was the best man at my and so we were
close and who who was I thought you
thought and who was um who was the mom
like how what was she like oh an an was
very nice she was sweet she was very
nice and very nice lady
softspoken um gentle uh loving and had
all nice things she said I looked I
reminded her of of of my of my dad oh
yeah yeah that kind of thing so she was
very nice every time she'd come to
Washington DC she'd look me up okay yeah
so so what what happened where was The
Fallout The Fallout was number okay um
because what was it you had to you were
there I assume when he became president
were you guys close then yeah we were at
that time things weren't so bad because
we were still like what do you call
Related right if you know what I mean
yeah we were related so are you are you
not related H we are related but not
related in that way because if feel like
you have sisters and brothers and so
forth yeah and there's there's that that
about being you
know a brother or a sister you know so
no matter what you're still together but
once he became started getting famous
and uh getting all these positions and
so forth especially when he was in
Illinois in in Chicago you know I didn't
get to communicate with him that much
not really we were doing our own things
and in 1995 I decided I want to go home
you know I had a spiritual awakening and
I want to go back to my roots I was into
Malcolm X and all that stuff and I
didn't want to be close to white people
and you know you know at that time that
was what was going on okay yeah that's
my story you should read my book I have
a book The Big B brother from Kenya okay
yeah so you should read it you know so
but it happened it's almost like Malcolm
X how he was you know the white man is a
devil everything and then he got
enlightened and it wasn't that way
anymore you know so but at 1995 I said I
packed up my stuff I was working at
Fanny May I'd been there for almost 10
years I was doing pretty well I was
moving up and everything and I got tired
I said to hell with all this Western
World stuff and everything I'm going to
go back and put and wear my skins as an
African go back to my roots hey I'm
telling you it was something else so I
pack up all my stuff and I put it in the
container and so forth everything I quit
my job and I go back home and I'm there
for two years W so Malcolm X got you to
that's why I'm Malik wow okay he's
called Malik El shabaz yeah so I used to
be called Roy Roy and so I Chang my name
to Malik okay after Malcolm X oh wow
yeah imagine all that okay so uh so I go
back and two years took me two years and
I was broke all the money ran out and
everything and I had to come back to the
USA so I come back to the USA I just
come back and I land and I told the
brother I called him and I said bar I
got nowhere to stay can I come up and
stay with you and he says no you know so
he says no because something about
Michelle not being comfortable with it
it was Michelle that lady's bad
news you don't like Michelle no I don't
like Michelle if she's stand she want to
be and I think she's one of the reasons
why maybe me and my brother don't get
along it was because of Michelle and she
may be the one who has him buy the
balls I'll tell you what I'll tell you
what about I'll tell you what I'll tell
you what about Michelle okay so she
actually did commit an atrocity let me
explain okay let me explain when I was
in U Middle School or high school I
can't remember when it was I think high
school maybe she passed them like there
was something for like healthier school
lunches we used to get cookies okay she
took them away she took them away yeah
it was terrible cuz she was passing all
this healthy stuff so they made it like
illegal to have I don't remember how I
just know that before I had cookies and
after no well Joel Gilbert has has a
film out right now and says that you
know and a book and he does claim that
she's fake as a snake too you know and
that she's evil and she did all all bad
stuff and here you go saying that she
took away your
cookies so so there must that that's
pretty evil yeah there must be some
truth she's an evil woman chip she's
evil she's really evil she's bad news
yeah because she separated me from from
my brother if he's my brother okay so if
he's your brother cuz I have who was
present for his birth I have no idea oh
you don't know no I don't know so you
just this is just based off of what you
were told yeah just you know like I said
we got together and because of what I
was told I just you know like welcome
welcomed him and that was my brother you
know that was it you know at face value
you know I had no question no doubt no
nothing I just took him in in my
heart so you tweeted interesting article
I met Sheila when I went to Chicago
after fake ass a snake President Barack
Obama had come down to Washington DC for
our first meeting in
1985 always nice girl always wondered
what happened to her yeah she sort of
just disappeared because in 1985 when I
did when he came down and we got to know
one another he came down to Washington
DC and uh we uh that's how our
relationship started
and so I went up to Chicago you know to
see him and uh so Sheila was his
girlfriend at the time I remember that
because there's a song
by um is it Sheila E was with Prince and
uh that outfit out there Oh
Sheila yeah that kind of thing so I
remember her real well because um when I
went out there
he was with her you know and and all of
a sudden she just disappeared you know
after that I don't know what happened to
her you know so um I think there was an
article somewhere that about her
recently um that came out and uh and
that's why I put her in my
tweet because I don't know what happened
to her up until now I haven't seen her
back in 1985 all of a sudden it was it
was it was Michelle right yeah and you
don't know how they met I don't know how
they met or anything because the first
time I met Michelle was when I went for
the wedding that was the first time you
met her that's the first time I met her
in
1992 yeah that's the first time wow I
didn't even know who he was with or
anything I was out here in Washington DC
and he was up there in Chicago and I
don't even think he was a state senator
at the time 1992 maybe maybe not but I
had gone for the event you know that
wedding event and I was introduced to
her this is Michelle blah blah blah like
that and everybody was there Maya was
there the mother was there we were all
there my sister was there Rita was there
and uh and that's how I met Michelle so
the second time was when she came down
to my wedding MH and that's the closest
that we've been really like in terms of
like being close you know so we spent
time together and this and that we you
know cracked jokes and so forth but
after that not really I have not had any
like d
direct personal close relationship with
Michelle she sort of like has always
been in the background when we came for
25 20 2005 Senator when he became a
senator there was the inauguration yeah
he show was like in the background we
didn't even get really to see one
another you know sit like I'm sitting
with you and talk so I haven't really
like again communicated with Michelle
since
19 93 at my wedding okay that's when we
really spoke so she's just one of those
she's a bad bad so why do you if you've
barely spoken to her why do you have the
the opinion of her you do yeah because I
have a feeling that you know if she was
really
like she would have wanted us to be
together you know to have the same
relationship we had before you know me
being the other brother oh but that's
kind of when it switched was when she
came in was that that's when your
relationship switched when she came in
no what what happened was that okay like
when I came back to the to the USA in
and I wanted a place to
stay and the reason I was given was that
she wouldn't be comfortable with it you
know so immediately I said you know hey
I'm his brother you know I I should be
have you know
have to be able to stay with him you
know but if she's the one that was
preventing me anyway but after but the
reason that me and Barack really didn't
get because I felt like he didn't have
the balls you know he didn't wasn't had
control he's being led by this woman
yeah that kind of thing and uh that he
had abandoned me now uh the other thing
was that
okay uh what can I say by by good chance
and so forth I F I got a place you know
I came in here I was at the I just
dropped in I was at the train station
the Metro I called a friend friend said
okay he had a house he had a room Yeah
by all means come so I stayed with him
from that time for about seven years I
was staying with at his place so when I
was at with
Joe so Barak he calls me you and he's
upset that I can come to the USA and not
let him know that I'm here and I said to
myself brother how am I supposed to call
you when you couldn't let me stay at
your place for all you know I could be
in the gutter someplace you know know I
could be homeless for that matter so why
are you getting upset and so he was
really upset and the other thing is that
my aunt up there in Boston Zuni is
having a hard time and you're not giving
any assistance you know you're not you
know helping her out you know so there
were two things I didn't have a place to
stay and also he was not you know he
wasn't uh concerned about what's going
on with my aunt and this Aunt of mine is
the one who welcomed him when he came to
Kenya in 1988 for his first visit I'm
the one who made him go there because I
told him we got to go and I want you to
go and see you know and meet your family
and all that stuff so he came so they
all welcome welcomed him as a family
member you know and they treated him
real good and so forth so now when she's
in bad shape he again abandoned her he
wasn't doing that so that was where we
really CL flashed cuz he wasn't he
didn't want he didn't like the way that
I was talking down to him or like
scolding him and uh so there from there
on you know it wasn't really like that
bad but it wasn't like we were not close
you know like taking each other for
granted you know there's a closeness
where you take somebody for granted you
know you don't have any questions you
know oh if I come to your place and I
knock there's no issues there are no
issues but then the issue started from
there you know so okay go ahead you got
some questions or you want me to go on
no keep going so uh all right so after
that
um okay so he goes on with his stuff his
state senator blah blah blah so forth
and so on I'm going on for my stuff and
everything and then uh okay comes a time
now he's getting real popular you he's
getting known is going to be the first
senator of Chicago he's in the news and
all that stuff back home in in Africa
people oh this is our son uh this and
that so it's a big thing all right so
it's a really big thing and I have a
feeling that also the press and the
media they were up to something because
again they had a lot of misinformation
you know put they put out number one
they put out the wrong location they
little little things you know media is
really yeah they can they can change
just one word and has a different
context and a different meaning you know
they're Sinister and they're mean the
media so they did all those kind of
things so that we wouldn't be close
there would be an issue always there's
something going on yeah oh I'm a Muslim
this and that oh I'm this thing I'm so
the media is coming for you too yeah
Muslim Brotherhood all this and that so
they never and of course he was like
trying to get up up there and he was I
think concerned about his image and
everything uh and so we wouldn't not one
time did he ever invite me to his home I
have never been to his home you know
even for dinner you know just for a
weekend or anything like that so to me
that hurt me somewhat because what did I
do to him did I sleep with a wife did I
do what you know kind you ask yourself
some questions what really horrible
thing did I do you know other than I was
calling him out for you know we call
each other out and I would call him but
I don't think he lik that so I'm
thinking that what I did at that time
may have would have uh uh brushed him
the wrong way and he didn't like that
and when I look at him like Obama
himself he doesn't like anybody who's
you know telling him what to do he wants
to be on the spotlight you know so
that's how it came and at at the
inauguration we were there okay that was
okay I came down and uh we attended that
and at the end of the day we also
attended the
um the presidential inauguration and
came there uh and so forth and but after
he became President when he was uh
elected the president we had a talk we
were still talking I had his email
address and everything you know he would
call me and i' call him I had his number
so we would still talk so at that time
when he was elected we had a long
discussion and I told him oh brother
this and that I could assist you can I
work for you maybe I can help you this
and that he told me that that that I'm
not a citizen of the United
States and I said to myself I've been in
the USA from 1985 legally and working I
have a green card and so forth why
wouldn't I be able to work for you so
number one I had set up uh my Foundation
I still have it running the Barra H
Obama Foundation uh in memory of our dad
and I told Barack I said
look this is a foundation that is in
memory of our dad I need you so he said
I want you to he wanted me to to what
you to to to put it down you know to
take it take it down you know I said no
I can't do it so we clashed there too
and uh and so um we had our issues and
so forth in the beginning and to me it
was like he didn't want me close to him
um for whatever reason but I'm thinking
that they may have been some issues
there like the Optics right of me being
there and me being a black has cold you
know so maybe if I went over there I
might be out of place in in the white
house and all his friends so forth hey
am just telling you all this okay so
that's when you know things started
changing
because I didn't get the the
feel that we were had a relationship it
was like always like there was that you
know keep off you know he was trying to
keep me off and you stay there and I
stay here and even the time that IID
visit the White House I would make the
effort
I would never really invited to that
place so at the end of the time at the
end of his term I never said anything in
public I was always in support of him
you know if somebody said something and
say oh is he a Muslim is he that I said
no he's a Christian you know oh what do
you think what about his background and
so okay is he Kenyan no I said no he's
American you know that kind of thing I
always try to support him you know and
the hope hope that one day he's going to
acknowledge my support So at the end of
his uh his
term his second term now around 2015
something like that you know we sat down
and I said okay these are kind of things
that we need to do and we promise he
told me I'm not going to say what it is
but there were some things that we were
supposed to do I think he was supposed
to set up some fund of scholarship fund
for my children and all that stuff he
prom me me a couple of things you know
but as time went on I said it seemed
like this is he's not going to do any of
this and I said to hell with him you
know hell with that I've been waiting
almost all this time to see if there's
any any any sign you know that maybe he
might you know approach and come closer
you know but I saw nothing because
always it was like even if I went there
he was too busy he you give me like 10
minutes maybe 20 minutes I got to go M
yeah she was too busy with other things
I said to myself hey this is too much
okay so what happened was that after all
this you know and then the Democrat the
way they were were coming out um Hillary
Clinton and so forth to the emails and
so forth and and it seemed to me like
these guys were all fake they were H
Hypocrites because they say one thing
and they do another like
the uh uh Secretary of
State how can he she not know that
sending these kind of emails are
improper and she's the secretary of
state right you know they're the ones
who set the rules and they supp they
have their security briefings they have
their so-called you know she's the in in
inside so you came to the conclusion
that they're all fake they're all fake I
just said to myself it was a waste of
time it wasn't worth the effort and do
you feel like he was always fake or do
you think it it gradually became like do
you think he was always like that and
maybe you missed it or he gradually
became like
that it's hard to say because he came
across as genuine in the beginning you
know and then again my attitude at the
time was that to take him at face value
you know but I'm thinking that probably
that was all a setup you know because he
wanted to use that as the narrative as
the basis the
platform for
his uh what he is for his
presidency you know that uh narrative
that here he is his father was so and so
and this is the USV and the USA is that
kind of country who is going to who can
get a president you know not there are
no restrictions you know the Democracy
here the kind of set up you know the the
Constitution of the United States you
know and so forth and this is America
and America can do this somebody
who's completely what do you call it uh
a different person that can be
accommodated and become president of the
United States so my thing is that maybe
that was the bill that was the the
buildup and uh the plan because he
always told me you got to have a plan so
I'm thinking that was the plan for a
long time ago that's how they were going
to do it I'm I'm not sure who it is but
maybe they're you know in conjunction
with some people in power in powerful
POS you know put him in in this place so
when did you decide to start speaking
publicly um because I know um there's
going to be people in the audience that
say you're just jealous of his success
and that's why you're
speaking Yeah I don't think it's any
they will say that but to me it's got
nothing to do with jealousy because he
was my brother you know I loved him I
took him
unconditionally you know and I supported
him through the whole his PR pres you go
and look anywhere and you see there was
no
criticism I did not
go against him and uh I gave him all the
support that he needed until the end of
his presidency then I realized that he
was fake well even how did you feel when
he made gay marriage legal well I'm a
musim yeah because I'm like that has to
go they that does not fly in Africa yeah
I was I I didn't support that and I said
to myself that anybody who would do that
must be somebody who has a doesn't have
a stand you know and then uh okay I have
gay friends not like I don't have gay
friends but I don't condone it I mean I
would I don't think that man and man or
woman and woman is a natural what do you
call it uh condition right you see so I
didn't support that you know and I'm not
sure if he's doing it because he's part
of that ask you
know or uh he's tring to please somebody
yeah or he's just like U he doesn't he
stands for anything you know did you um
did you see the recent interview of the
guy that claimed he slept with Barack
Obama but I didn't see it but I've heard
about it that guy uh Sinclair yeah you
think it's true why would anybody go out
there and passionately say things like
that just for no reason why
you know why would there I mean Cloud's
a powerful drug what Cloud's a powerful
drug I think that's what people would
say people will say things for attention
money no I have a feeling that where
there fire this smoke yeah where there
fire this smoke and a person to go and
just
uh make those
claims you and they dangerous claims you
know there must have been something
going on what do you think about the
claims that Michelle Obama as a man have
you heard that well Michelle when I
first met her she looked very much like
a woman you okay on those days but I
haven't seen her I haven't been close to
her for a very long time like I said
since
200 since
1992 right 1992 before I was born that's
a long that's a long time ago you know
what I'm saying and these days what I
see of her is in the press the media
pictures and my question is how can she
all of a sudden be so
big I don't know you know and then at
times when she's on her like the mo the
the her book the cover of her book she
looks so different she looks like a
woman she's so pretty and everything and
all of a sudden when you see a like uh
something she has broad so shoulders
yeah and she's B she looks like a man
even right now if you see the pictures
of her in France she looks like a man
you know but right now there's a picture
of her when they're celebrating their uh
is it their 30th year marriage the
anniversary she looks like a woman again
so I'm saying what's going on is she on
drugs is she on something she she's
morphing she's changing so that's also
very interesting in that
what is she you know who is she and then
you have the picture of her with Ellen
degenerous the one and you know you can
see something like you
know a dick you
know yeah you know what I'm saying and
you wonder you know are you really
seeing this is it really true is it what
so I have questions whether Obama is gay
I have questions right you know it's not
like the other day you're not you're not
certain one way I'm not sure anymore I'm
not sure I can't say because I can't say
she's a man because I haven't seen her
naked right you know but you didn't know
her nakedness right but if she was you
wouldn't know because you didn't even
meet her till the wedding day no no it's
hard to say you know these days you
can't even tell I mean are you a
woman no I'm just saying I'm just saying
these days you can't tell you got the
transgender people you got like this
this is it malany the oh Dylan Mal Dylan
malany oh come on Dylan wouldn't fool
you she looks like a girl no yeah yeah
she does and she won the the the the the
what do you call it the woman of the
year award yeah yeah hey you can't tell
anymore you know you see what I'm saying
so it's hard but no no really seriously
it's difficult to say okay difficult to
say I'm not sure anymore on August 26th
23 you tweeted out if my father Barack
Obama is fake a as a
snake
um then fake at as a snake Barack
Obama's ancestral home is Kenya and he
fake as a snake President Barack Obama
is Kenya yeah what I was trying to say
this is that if if my if my brother fake
is a snake Barack Obama
president if his father is Barack Obama
you know my father you know and my
father is Kenyan
then because his father is is a Kenyan
then he's a
Kenyan okay but do you think he was born
in Kenya not that he was born in Kenya
but like let's say if May if if I'm an
American right now and I have children
in in Kenya right are they not American
or are they Kenyan oh they are both both
I guess both but they're both but
they're still but they're still American
right right yeah just like he if his
father is Kenyan right and he's born in
in the USA is he not
Kenyan yeah he's part Kenyon he's he's
mixed doesn't he think he's yeah he's
mixed okay his mother's American yeah
but because I think paternally because
the world is is a paternal world and
culturally even you asked me about the
culture of Kenya and everything but as
far as we're concerned we take on the
nationality uh of the father right say
for example in my culture all right uh
you have a household or a family your
father and a mother okay so when you're
born say I'm from like right now from
kumu it's a place called kisumu I'm a
luu and I'm from kisumu and uh there's a
the in kisumu there's different areas
like I'm from allego you know and then
um my wife say for example okay say
you're my wife okay and we go back to
Kenya okay and we have children okay my
children are Kenyan our children are
Kenyan okay are you getting me I
understand yeah yeah so is me and you
and we are children yeah the children
would be my nationality oh not the
mother's okay not the mother's National
yeah and in most cultures that's how it
is because even if it's a religion and
so forth you're supposed to assume your
husbands right I don't know but you talk
about this a lot yeah and well I think
we would just say mixed here you talk
about this a lot but traditionally even
in England I think that that's how it
was it was yeah even in Europe I think
that's how it was yeah until all this
stuff came about with the feminism all
this stuff going around and nobody
really knows what's going on anymore you
know so but that's how it is and that's
how it was you know but because okay um
he was born in the USA okay so I guess
accordingly be because he was born here
then he's an American yes but you could
still argue that he's a Kenyan because
his father is a Kenyan also if that is
his father and you're not sure that's
his father no I'm just saying that if he
claims he says that is his father then
he's Kenyan because his father was
Kenyan okay but you have you seen the I
cuz I ever since I was a kid I always
saw articles saying that oh that that
Barack Obama wasn't born
here well I can't say because I wasn't
there yeah you weren't there you I
wasn't there you know and um he's been
all over he's been but he could have
been born here I mean and he says he's
born here so he's born here there's
nothing wrong with that but when you
think the logic behind what I said was
that his father was Kenyan and and if
his father was alive his father would
have the right to claim him and say this
is my son and my father definitely would
be if we alive would say that he's
Kenyan so you also tweeted out long time
you like the word fake as a snake is a
snake I'm I'm going to read I'm going to
read you tweeted out long time ago go
fake as a snake President Barack Obama
and I made a pack and he broke it a
betrayer and a traitor broke my heart
okay so I was um I used to drink a lot
you know I was an alcoholic I stopped
drinking I used to drink I used to smoke
I used to do drugs I used a whole bunch
of stuff I was wild Reckless young wild
Reckless and wild and and uh yeah wild
and Reckless at the time you know Young
wild and Reckless okay so then I stopped
you know and everybody was happy oh
Malik stopped drinking and call me Roy
stopped drinking everybody even he was
happy and so what we what he said was
that uh that he would never let me down
he would he would always be there for
meh and that's what he said and we had
that agreement you see so so even when
let's say when I I didn't have a place
to stay and I came back to the USA I
knew that he was my brother and I didn't
I had a place to stay no matter what so
you see he betrayed me up until now heay
he has betrayed me because he's kept me
at arms
length as if he doesn't want me close to
him you know um even White House I could
have and that's why I like TR you know
and when in
2015 I realized that there was no I was
not getting anywhere with this guy you
know all of a sudden Trump came on the
scene and Trump was like he was he tell
you off especially like when and I felt
really good when he told Clinton Clinton
Hillary Clinton off at the Press Club
you remember that
yeah that was cute I like jail
he really did you know and to me that
that was really exciting to have
somebody who speak his mind right and he
wasn't afraid you know to speak his mind
you know and here was this guy Barak he
was always like trying to look proper
and do the right thing and it's like he
was a puppet and he had to you know here
was his brother he don't want he doesn't
want me close to him because I might
for uh put you know some kind of the
image might not be the right image I I
might offend or it might offend some
people right you know what I'm saying
but here was Trump trump was telling
these people off you know and he was
like even when he came to the Muslims
and so forth you know he had a point
there because these guys are blowing
everybody up if it weren't for the
Muslims the world wouldn't be the way it
was right now these people coming here
and blowing up the buildings and so
forth we wouldn't have to be taking off
our shoes at the airport you know
traveling was was great at the time we
used to have a good time you travel you
go places but now traveling is like it's
a hassle it's like a hardship you you
could lose your passport they're going
to take you you can't you can't uh carry
a nail clipper you don't how do you how
do you cut your nails you know you can't
your shaver small small things that help
you you can't do that because of
somebody who came around and blew up
everybody and now you know everybody so
hyper about security yeah you know uh so
um things changed and uh when when Trump
came along it was like a a breath of
fresh air and something came up in like
there was a a light bulb just went on
and I said to oh these Democrats these
guys you know they tell you one thing
but they do another they tell you one
thing and they do another and here
Hillary Clinton is lying she was
actually lying you know and trying to
get off of that lie because she felt
like she was Untouchable you know and
and she was entitled to what reles and
Trump was in here and he was Against All
Odds everybody was up against him right
you know nobody thought he would win
nobody thought he would win you know and
he was like a bll fighter he was like
telling them off and and I said to
myself hey I'm GNA go for this guy and
they'll piss this guy off also you know
and what happened when you so then did
you publicly support Trump yeah I mean
even right now I still support him I'm
going to vote for him too and how did
you hear from Barack Obama when you did
that no I didn't hear from him he he
just he's like he just linked away he's
like he withdrew yeah you know and it
seemed like he got rid of whatever
problem that I was because it seemed
like I was a problem you know he
couldn't here I was now he got you know
I got he got rid of me who controled R
Barack Obama and what do you believe
motivates
him my thinking is that people like the
clintons you know they're the ones who
control everything like Democratic party
you know he when he came in there you
know to become the president and uh get
the nomination everything he had to do
all the right things had to talk to all
the right people you know and and the
clintons I think they have a lot of uh
CL
at least at the time I don't about now
but I'm thinking so still right you know
so my thinking is that now my friend
Gary he says it's the RO child you know
who's doing all this could be I have a
feeling R child control everything you
know that's my own thing because they're
like the that wealth is like this old
old old wealth you know what I'm saying
so they've been doing all that stuff but
for right now I think it's like the
clintons they have uh their tentacles
all over the Democrats in fact even
losing
was it's a mystery how they lost right
you know um but those are the people
somebody is controlling him and telling
him what to do Etc my friend Gary thinks
that he's the one who's controlling them
but I think that somebody's controlling
him yeah you think that they're the
basically the clintons are controlling
him I think so yeah so on August 19th
you tweeted out is this normal there
somebody had tweeted um sleepy or sloppy
joe that I call him that's Joe
Biden that guyy is so old man he
wouldn't even know the door if you
showed him the door you know so what
happened is I think he was there was a
there was a video of him like uh what do
you call it what did they say he was he
was stro cing some some small child and
from what I hear was his grandchild or
something like that so I said is this
normal the way he's always funling the
the young people yeah you know the kids
and everything is this normal so that's
what I said it was in relation to to
president U Joe Joe Biden you didn't
think it was normal no I don't think it
noral there's something going on with
that guy too I think he's like whe
there's smoke there's fire no I think
he's a pervert Yeah yeah really think so
because all the things that I always is
drawing these kids and kissing them and
doing this and not just once but many
times you know so there's something
going on there with him
too why did Barack Obama say there's
only one person you should not hire
General Michael Flynn there are two
people in the world you cannot trust one
of them is Putin and one of them is
General Michael
Flynn I don't know they put that
question out there but I can't tell
because I don't really know General
Flynn not really I had an interview with
him the other day him and Ray Ray uh
Clark uh the people who are put up this
to reawaken America I had an interview
with with with General Clark General
Flynn and he seemed like a good person
he seemed like a personable guy um and
but for for for for this question in
terms of like why Obama said that
General Flynn shouldn't be picked for
any position in the Trump
Administration I don't know I have an
idea because otherwise unless because
Flynn is a military man and I think he
was a senior military man even in the
Obama Administration something may have
happened in the for Obama to say that
but I don't know because I don't know
General Flynn not really why why are you
so outspoken for your support of Donald
Trump like I said Donald Trump your face
lights up he he has attributes that I
like and that's how I like that's why
it's me like the other day I was just
speaking my mind you know just saying
these guys you forgot your hat what does
your hat say ah
B I wish I could have had
it we we'll put up a picture of it tell
them what it says can put it on yeah I
just did that as a pun you know what I
mean you I like to do things like that
you know like this um when I say I stand
for Palestine I don't mean that I want
the Palestinians to go killing people
and what they did was horrible you know
nobody goes around hacking somebody and
trying to take off their head and and
also that's un Islam
Islamic you don't do things like that
you know but you can understand why
maybe they're doing that because if
they've been bombed and they don't have
water and they don't have food and
they're they're kept in there in a cage
they're caged you know what do you
expect is there going to be some
violence there some hatred you know and
they've seen a lot of atrocities going
on things going on maybe the Mosk
they're being mistreated at the mosque
and so forth and and they have to get
permission to go places you know so it's
a large concentration camp over there
and my thinking is that like the
Israelis they should have some
compassion because they went through a
lot of persecution and horrible stuff
was done to them and they shouldn't be
the ones to do the same things to others
you know but the Palestinian thing and
the Middle East thing has been a long
drawn things and I blame the British
because they're the ones who you know
started in that thing about
you know
petitioning that
land and they should be around now at
least to do so I don't see them and the
United States is the taking center stage
and I feel that the Brit Brit Britain or
UK British they should take Center Stage
because that was their thing they're the
ones who started it they're the ones who
made all those decisions on who should
get what and who should get this you
know but here's the USA America is being
drawn into in into that so when I said I
stand with with Palestine I'm just
saying I stand with them and that their
grievances are there I'm not saying that
Isel needs to go out that they don't
they should
live side by side and I I do support the
two-state solution where you have Israel
and Palestine living side by side
because you can there's no way that you
can get rid of the the the Israelis
they're already there
and there's no way you can get the rid
of the Palestinians but my real thinking
here is that maybe because when this
thing happened on on SE on October the
7th yeah there was a
Gateway in the iron shield that Shield
that protects
Israel now that thing is supposed to be
closed all the
time because they know the Rockets are
going to come and what else so it was
opened I have a feeling that it was
opened for them to come in so they were
trigger this thing and then Israelis
will go in there flatten G Gaza go
occupy it you know and then maybe next
time then then go to West Bank maybe and
so they have a unified
Israel you know but it's got nothing I
don't think it has anything to do with
normal Israelis or the ordinary
Palestinians but somebody up there
they've got this thing going you know so
that's what I say poor people they're
having a hard time not only are they
having a hard time they really having
because if they are also like in a cage
because they can't move around freely
like they want it's a war zone out there
so that's how it
was so tell us about your book Big B big
bad brother from Kenya a big bad brother
from Kenya there you go
now this book of mine it took me forever
to write it I started writing it back in
96 something like that
1997 okay you know so if you see the
opening sentence it says ba ba is baba
baba ba father so my son who was four at
the time I was just sitting there you
know on my bed just and he comes and
says ba you know just like that and
that's how it started and it took me
like up
until
20 20
22 you know that's when I published this
thing to finish it i' been writing it on
F scap you know just writing and writing
it's a story of my life it's an
autobiography from uh you know where I
started you know when I was a child all
the way to now you know it's about our
family it's about my dad it's about my
siblings my relatives you know being
in uh raised in Kenya coming to the
United States my experiences here in the
USA you know and um and then my
relationship with Obama you know my
first meeting with him and how the story
developed and our relationship
developed uh how I ran for office in
Kenya you know and uh he didn't give me
support for that you know and I still
feel like hurtful it's not it's not a
matter of jealousy you it's just like
that's what brothers are for you know so
he didn't give me support for that I
wrote a book about my dad you know the
um Barack Obama senior the
a rise in life of a true African scholar
it's on Amazon I gave him the manuscript
I told him get do me a forward he
wouldn't write a for for me but he go
and write a for for Mandela he go and
write a for for all these people but he
won't write a for for me about our own
dad you know that to me that hurt me you
know so why not you know so he did it
for all these people and couldn't do it
could do it for me he couldn't do it you
know I said to myself why for what
reason you know I had known I nothing
bad from me the best man at your wedding
you know you know all that
so yeah so the big big bad brother from
Kenya came up you know number one uh
it's a story of my life I just wanted to
put something in writing you know um and
I did it all by myself nobody helped me
with it everything I did it Joel Gilbert
he helped me with the cover and so forth
he did the graphics for it Joel was at
the function yesterday I don't know if
you know him he's the one who says that
that Barack Obama is not my brother that
he's the son of Frank Marshall Davis you
know yeah so he says okay so he's also
somebody that's another thing story for
another day you know but
so that's the book and I hope people
will buy it where can they get it you
can get it on Amazon just go on Amazon
and type in uh uh Malik Obama big bad
brother from Kenya and it'll come up
there are three versions I've got three
versions of it I have uh the color
version we have a lot of pictures in
there you have the black and white white
version um and then you have the Kindle
then you have the Kindle and actually
there there's another book that I have
just the pictures just pictures and then
it's called iconic epic Malik Obama in
pictures so you can Google go there in
and Amazon and you can get that one too
so what I was just trying to do was you
know put my life in in and in writing so
that people can if you really want to
know what's going on you can get the
book and you can read it so I urge and
encourage everybody to you know to buy
it and uh at least you understand my
thoughts and you understand uh our
family you know how it is because even
with Obama Barack he asked me I went
through his his book the first book of
his um what was it called uh The
Inheritance book okay he sent me the
manuscript asked me to go over now
that's how close we were in the
beginning he'd have me go over the book
to see if there's anything that I need
he needs to change is it okay does it
make sense etc etc you know so um
yeah by the book well thank you for
coming on today is there anywhere else
the people can follow you at uh no I'm
on Twitter um I got an account on Tik
Tok and Instagram but just because I
don't have time for all that I'm
basically just on Twitter on Obama obam
Malik I think that's it at Obama Malik
that's it and you can get me there and
uh hopefully uh you'll be able to U
enjoy some of my tweets yeah I like the
fake as a snake on fake as a snake yeah
that guy is he changed you know he not
what I thought he was but right now you
know he's a even right now he got a
Nobel Peace Prize and my thinking was
that he would be somewhere doing
something you know to bring peace around
the world but you don't see he just
raking up a lot of money with his
foundation but even the foundation I
don't know what it's doing because I
don't see it now the other thing with
him is that if you look closely Bill
Clinton had something called uh
AOA which is the trade organiz it makes
trading with Africa a lot easier you
know and then uh George Bush he had the
Pepa which is something to do with AIDs
that has helped a lot of people in
Africa now Obama I think the only thing
that we can think of say about him is uh
Obamacare which is here in the United
States that's a disaster and and it's
not free I try to get on that and they
ask you for
money you know and how is anybody going
to sign up for that if they themselves
don't have the money right even for
healthcare right so I gave up on that I
don't think that it's what it's really
designed to be you know maybe no it's
pretty much vied as a failure in America
yeah so like I'm saying so what I'm
saying is my thing is that Obama is
going to be remembered only for being
the first africanamerican or black
president of the United States or
nothing
else but he could have done a lot of
things you see Trump you know he went
and did he he's he does unusual stuff he
does out of the ordinary he went to
North Korea yeah shook hands with with
with Kim
Don how do you pronouncing his name Kim
D
J I think
it's now Gaddafi used to be was a friend
of mine and Gaddafi sent me down to
Obama to Barack he just wanted to be
friends that was a great opportunity for
him you know to make peace because there
all this stuff going on and if he had me
and that's what I tried to get him to do
to get me to use me as a Muslim oh to
like make peace yeah you could send me
stuff places you know publicly maybe or
or even even quietly and I could go and
make things right you know I could go
talk to these people and this and that
and and you know relation things would
be bring peace right you know and he
couldn't do that he wouldn't do that he
could have used me right yeah but he
didn't do that you know and Gaddafi also
wanted he could have made peace with
with Gaddafi and you see Trump did it
right yeah he did it you know Trump did
a lot of things that people
don't don't don't acknowledge or they
forget and there was no war there were
no wars during his period his time you
know and this building of the wall is a
great idea because people are building
walls all over the place even in Kenya
they're building a wall yeah you know
what I'm saying and what's wrong with
that if these people are going to stream
in into the United States now they just
coming I took it took me forever to
bring my daughter here the and I finally
managed to bring her here in August I
had to go through the process and it's
it's a long process but I did it and
she's here legally you know why don't
these people also go through the legal
way right you
know I agree you see what I'm saying so
there's nothing wrong with what Trump
did and what I'm saying the I'm a Muslim
myself but I don't support violence I
don't support terrorism you know going
around and terrorizing people and
because in the name of Allah Allah does
not say go to terrorize people we are
supposed to be making friends and making
peace in a way that people will attract
people to the religion and they say this
is a good religion you know I like this
you know but if you start like blowing
people up and this and that and you know
no I don't support that yeah yeah I
agree okay Trump 2024 right 2024 yes
vote for Trump yes well thank you so
much for coming on um guys thank you so
much for watching um we're going to keep
having more and more guests on the
sitdown so let me know in the comments
who you guys want me to have next you a
great guest thank you so much for coming
like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time
I